Welcome back to our course on debugging.
Today's topic is tracking origins,
meaning how to start with a failure
and track back origins of the failure until you find the defect that causes it.
But before we get there, a bit of a story.
If you are a fan of Sherlock Holmes,
you may recall this famous scene in "A Scandal in Bohemia."
Here we have Dr. Watson and Sherlock Holmes sitting by the fireplace.
They haven't seen each other for some time,
and Sherlock remarks that Watson has put on 7-1/2 pounds since they last met.
And Watson says, "How do you know?"
And Sherlock answers, "I see. I deduce it."
Not only does Sherlock find out that Watson has put on 7 pounds,
he also remarks that Watson has been getting very wet lately
and that his servant girl is clumsy and careless.
Again, Watson asks, "How on earth did you find that out?"
"Oh, it is simplicity itself," Sherlock says.
What Holmes sees is that on the inside of Dr. Watson's shoe
there is a small number of scratches,
which he can see in the firelight.
He deduces that these scratches have been applied by somebody
who very carelessly tried to clean the shoe,
possibly Dr. Watson's servant.
And since the shoe had to be cleaned with such a rough device,
this likely came from mud through which Dr. Watson had to run
while getting very wet.
This is how Sherlock Holmes, from a single observation,
can deduce all the events that led to this observation.
I should add that, faced with this explanation,
Dr. Watson exclaims, "When, Sherlock, I hear you give your reasons,
the thing always appears to me to be so ridiculously simple
that I could easily do it myself.
Though, at each successive instance of your reasoning,
I am baffled until you explain your process."